obviously turkey homemade mashed
potatoes for sure macaroni and cheese
sweet potatoes definitely a turkey sweet
potatoes and mac and cheese have to have
a turkey with stuffing inside of the
turkey it's Trad
I need the Turkey um just cuz it's a
classic dish macaroni and cheese and Cal
green it's the best side dishes I don't
care what anyone says sweet potato must
be over there I love mashed potato so it
has to be there too
stuffing because you don't eat it every
day you know it's a special occasion two
things rud begas number one number two
Trash Can Turkey Trash Can Turkey it's
absolute must have twice baked potato
that would be one of my favorites with
it homemade sweet potato pie my own
recipe I don't give it out I don't eat
pie yeah I don't eat pie I don't I'm not
really too into sweets you have to have
ham baked macaroni and greens oh yes and
potato salad them the most and the least
I don't like cranberry sauce that's a no
no I don't like that nobody should have
cranberry sauce on a dish at all
absolute must have mashed potatoes just
something about it CU always had it at
every meal and something about the taste
something about potatoes just growing up
in the midwest potatoes have always been
one of my favorite foods to eat so
absolutely mashed potatoes it's cozy
it's like it's just home to me basically
mac and cheese I would say probably it's
my favorite it's my favorite the one
that I I absolutely need for
Thanksgiving my mom makes the best
potato
tilet yes that's a must have yes yes yes
just so many different ways you can make
it I feel like sometimes people really
good ways of making it sometimes really
bad but like when it's done really well
it's done really really well so if you
got yams you got macaroni and cheese you
got to have greens you got to have
Greens Greens tops it all
off